how much would you pay for the best
player in the game what about two
million dollars well that's exactly how
much cloud9 wanted for tens valorent's
undisputed best player at least at the
time according to dot esports c9 ceo
jackie tien was shopping tens around
last may for three million dollars
eventually lowering it to two million
nadeshot revealed that they had a chance
to buy him but the buyout was the most
egregious thing that i've ever came
across in esports history it was an
unfathomable number now jack was a
little confused that's a confusing
statement as i offered tens to 100 for 2
million which i still feel was a fair
price many would stay too low for one of
the most beloved and highest skilled
esports star on the planet and honestly
it does sound like nadeshot has some
regrets in some ways i wish we would
have just paid the buyout we could have
had a hundred thieves tens and asana